My name is Mitchell Yerxa,
I'm a fourth generation farmer here in Colusa, California,
I currently farm with my family and
we've been farming the same ground for over 100 years.
Every year, there's a little bit more innovation.
We call it precision farming but Big Data is just truly data analysis.
It's how you can process and how you can take in every bit of information you can.
Every single day, we're using almost every level from algebra all the way
to higher in statistics or calculus to figure out not only the mapping,
chemical rates, but also the estimation of your product in your state versus
other products from other countries and how those might influence
how buyers choose your product over something else.
$930 billion is lost each year in either wasted food or overproduced food.
It's really been interesting to see a market in which people need food,
how do you not produce too much,
and how do you get it to the end consumer much quicker.
And so, it's been a really fascinating use of data,
whereas for a grocer or
a distributor or any kind of a middleman between the farmer and the consumer,
any time lost, any minute lost is value lost.
There's truly billions, if not hundreds of billions of dollars on the line.
We're able to look at every single sector of
every single field to say what did each portion every field do,
how did it do, what could it use more,
what could it use less of,
how we can be more productive with every square inch
of the same ground that we've been farming for four generations.
There's so much data out there,
it's just a matter of how do you utilize it simply.